you know at one time I had zero
awareness
about the importance of vitamins and
what they did on our bodies especially
vitamin D I've maybe heard about it
maybe you get it from the Sun from the
foods I just had zero data on vitamin D
and it just wasn't even on my radar but
over time when I gained more knowledge
about Vitamin D it is the most important
vitamin out of all the vitamins because
if you're deficient but your immune
system doesn't work you're going to have
inflammation you can have all sorts of
issues with sleep and digestion and the
list goes on and on and on but they may
know some of the common reasons why the
majority of the population is deficient
in vitamin D
gut inflammation no gallbladder as we
age our skin becomes thicker we can't
absorb vitamin D from the Sun the darker
the skin is the less vitamin D
absorption because of the melanin the
pigment in the skin the more obese
someone is
the more diabetic they are the more
insulin resistance they have the less
vitamin D they're going to absorb and
also where they live if they live at a
high latitude in the north they're not
going to get much deep and it's
virtually impossible to get vitamin D
from your diet people are also more
aware that their genetics have a big
play in vitamin D too there are many
different genes that a person can have a
problem with that either makes it
difficult to convert into the active
form of vitamin D or just absorb vitamin
D and I have that problem myself then
you have if a person has an infection
microbes can downgrade vitamin D
receptors and block the absorption
vitamin D as their strategy to overcome
your immune system if someone has a
fatty liver or they smoke or they
consume sugar or they go through stress
they're going to absorb less vitamin D
if they're on a Statin or on a low-fat
diet they're not going to get as much
vitamin D if there's pollution in the
air or even if they're getting too many
Omega six fatty acids with the soil oil
the corn oil the canola oil that will
block vitamin D but I want to talk about
seven things that you probably have
never heard of before and they're very
interesting and they're very important
to know number one
the majority of side effects that may
occur when you take vitamin D okay and
I'm going to list them fatigue insomnia
constipation diarrhea skin rash nausea
headache pain all could occur if you're
low in magnesium magnesium is such an
important mineral in relationship to
Vitamin D it helps it work better and if
you're deficient in magnesium which a
lot of people are vitamin D may give you
additional issues so in other words if
you take more Vitamin D it can
exaggerate an already deficient
situation with magnesium now of course
the side effect from very large amounts
of vitamin D over many many months
potentially creating hypercalcemia could
give you kidney stones but this is very
very rare and this I think is the
probably the biggest fear they don't
realize that you'd have to take a lot
more over a long period of time before
you got kidney stones or hypercalcemia
and if you're taking magnesium and other
factors related to this vitamin D like
K2 the odds of you getting hypercalcemia
too much calcium in the blood even go
even lower but drinking a little bit
more water like 2.5 liters of fluid per
day can really almost eliminate the
formation of kidney stones because
kidney stones form when there's a super
concentrated amount of this calcium in
the urine so if your urine is so diluted
it can never be super concentrated
number two taking vitamin D
infrequently Works a little bit better
than on a regular basis so if we compare
taking 10 000 IUS of vitamin D every day
as a maintenance dose and you instead
did 50 000 IUS once a week or twice a
week that might work a little better for
you and this is good because sometimes
people forget to take vitamin D and they
think is it going to do any good if I
take it if you few times a week and the
answer is yes remember vitamin D is a
fat soluble vitamin so when it goes in
the body it gets stored in the fat cells
and it's it can be released over time
it's not like a water soluble vitamin
like some of the B vitamins and vitamin
C that you would want to take those on a
daily basis the next thing that people
don't realize is this when you consume
like farm-raised fish which I mean it's
so so common in restaurants and you just
need to start reading the labels
farm-raised fish has four times less
vitamin D as well cod fish grain-fed
animals compared to grass-fed animals
have much less vitamin D and chickens
and pigs that roam outside and that are
able to get out of the barn and they're
exposed to the Sun have much more
vitamin D then these pigs and chickens
that are confined to a a structure in
fact when a pig or a chicken and doesn't
get to see the daylight they're like
three times less vitamin D all right
number four and this is really really
interesting
out of all the factors that can improve
your health okay vitamin D is behind
eating a healthy diet and exercise all
right number five
vitamin D2 which is mainly you have to
get a prescription for
is very different than vitamin D3 in
fact vitamin D2 actually in some Studies
have worsened MS okay versus vitamin D3
has greatly improved Ms lupus another
autoimmune disease is not affected by D2
but it is with D3 the studies in vitamin
D2 do not decrease mortality but the
studies with vitamin D3 do and taking
vitamin D2 can actually inhibit the
absorption of vitamin D3 all right next
Point okay some people when they go out
and get exposure to the sun they think
that they're getting a lot of vitamin D
when they're getting exposed to the Sun
for like 10 minutes so let's say Best
Care scenario you're young you don't
have any of these other barriers of
absorption vitamin D and you're exposing
a lot of your skin to the Sun for about
10 minutes you're only going to get 400
IU use the vitamin D that is very very
low amounts so just realize that it
takes a bit more exposure to Sun to get
enough vitamin D alright and last point
that I think is very very important
because a lot of people take vitamin D3
and they don't realize that
manufacturing companies are adding corn
syrup to vitamin D in fact the
manufacturing company that I work with
in Europe basically told me with a high
level of certainty I was the only one to
ask or request a vitamin D product
without corn syrup and I would suspect a
similar thing is happening in the U.S
but I don't know for sure so when you
get a vitamin D product make sure they
don't add the corn syrup or the
maltodextrin now that you know those
seven factors I want to take your
awareness even higher if you haven't
seen this video in vitamin D you should
check it out I put it up right here